good morning john i recorded this video
last night i wanted to
provide an update to it which is that uh
it looks like i'm about to give you some
bad news i'm not
just within the current context i want
to be clear that i'm feeling mentally
uh not great physically fine
okay good morning john oh boy it's
currently
what a clock in the morning oh my gosh
it's almost two i've been doing the
anxious scroll
to some extent not super surprising
there but in between that
i've been doing something wonderful
that i feel like a bad person for not
doing
more two reasons one in like the way
that you think i mean we're like i
should do this more because it's
it's good it's just a good thing to do
but two with the other in the other way
like i'm a bad i'm just bad at being a
person because this is so
obvious and so good and i like it and i
don't do it which is that i
called a friend i called two people
people who i don't like
call on the phone that often yeah we
talked something about kovan 19 but we
also talked about like
bread and star wars and work and
coffee and like the nor like stuff that
people talk about
and it was lovely when i'm doing the
anxious scroll
i feel as if i am doing something useful
and i'm seeing the same three to five
stories
over and over again so that they seem
like 300 to 500 stories
and i want to know more and i want to
know what it's going to be like tomorrow
and i want to know what it's going to be
like in three weeks and i feel like i'm
doing something
that's going to uncover that reality and
cover that truth and it is just
not but you call up a friend or you call
up a family member and all of it just
kind of goes away a little bit
and you can talk about movies talk about
books you talk about the past or talk
about the hard time a mutual friend is
going through and how
you guys are gonna help them and feel
ways and rant
and and get mad and be happy and
laugh you're up on twitter and it's like
don't forget stresslord is your immune
system and i'm like
okay first of all that's like
a little dubious what exactly that means
is complicated
second do you think that's gonna make me
less stressed out
yeah no but what does make me less
stressed out and maybe this isn't the
same for you
is calling a friend talking to him
somebody may be from a while ago
somebody you haven't talked to that much
somebody just want to check up on it and
say like hey
i think about you i care about you i
think you care about me i should do that
every day
it's it's good it feels good and the
more i don't do it the more i feel like
i
i can't do it so happy to have good
people in my life
and instead of searching for the next
the next scare for the next outrage
for the next piece of news the next bit
of context
i should be occupying all of this all of
the tremendous
power that i have at my disposal
connecting with someone john thanks for
hanging out my hotel bed
i'll see you on tuesday